la semana de la moda de parís se muestra
más exclusiva que nunca este año la
asistencia al desfile de dior estuvo
limitada a 300 personas contrario a los
miles que suelen asistir habitualmente
este fue el primer espectáculo
presencial tradicional que lleva
adelante una casa de modo importante de
parís desde el confinamiento impuesto en
la primavera y resultó más silencioso de
lo que están acostumbrados los invitados
yo creo que está perdiendo un poco de su
estilo es un poco triste todo el
folklore de la semana de la moda ya no
existe los eventos los abrazos
un eco del encierro en la pasarela las
modelos presentaron una colección con un
estilo de pijama suelto y fluido una
prenda adecuada para vestir y pasar
meses en espacios interiores
rabat life tenemos más vida privada
menos vida social entonces nuestra
relación también con la ropa es
completamente diferente porque creo que
podría ser más personal más en relación
con nuestro cuerpo con nuestro
sentimiento de bollywood a war feeling
el evento se vio interrumpido por un
infiltrado del movimiento rebelión
contra la extinción con una pancarta un
recordatorio que la industria de la moda
produce el 10 por ciento de todas las
emisiones de carbono de los humanos y es
el segundo mayor consumidor del
suministro de agua en el planeta